[Music]
this season we did something a little
different we divided the tribes based on
how others see them positive traits
associated with them so we have heroes
healers and hustlers a lot of likeable
people a lot of people that I think you
would like to see win and some people
with really relatable stories Allen is
on the hero tribe and one of the reasons
we put him on that tribe is in America
sports stars especially in the NFL are
celebrated and I think we put him on a
pedestal because they inspire us
Ellen is also a really likable guy he's
got a bright smile and an amazing energy
people are gonna know he's athletic
because the guy is ripped but he's got a
lot of big guys with him this season
he's lucky actually is fun ashley is a
lifeguard she's on the hero tribe
obviously she saves us from ourselves
but she's also willing just to go toe to
toe I think she's gonna do really well
she's really fun to be around she will
carry her weight in challenges and I
don't think she'll ever complain Ben is
the personification of a hero he
protected the United States at war and
Ben will say I'm not a hero I'm just
doing my job
that's why you're a hero I'm a family
man I'm a dad I'm a husband I'm a son
I'm a brother I'm a friend I don't know
I'm just a good guy little boy Krissi is
one of my all-time favorite people she
has accomplished so much 'über bright
big career took time off to go have a
family then came back to have another
big career she's a hero because she
shows especially other women you can do
anything especially anything any other
dude can do the thing working against
Krissi at least in her mind is that
she's one of the older people out here
she's so bright and has had so many life
experiences but I have a feeling she
will be able to maneuver people enough
to get them off that topic JP is on the
hero tribe he's a firefighter no other
explanation needed he goes into burning
buildings to save people I think he's a
little intimidated he might feel the
burden of all of what he brings with him
young fit good-looking a fireman you got
a lot to live up to man Katrina is on
the hero tribe because she's an athlete
she's
Olympic swimmer it's the highest level
in sports to make the US Olympic team
the biggest drawback for Katrina will be
her personality she's quirky and she
shares tend to be a little blunt you
know sometimes I miss her I had my mouth
shut so I hope Katrina can read the room
and say all right let me back off
because she's really likable person and
the longer she stays I think the more
people will realize what a good person
she is Cole is a super likable young man
and he's a wilderness guide he takes
kids that are having issues to say let's
try to work through these while we're
having an amazing adventure I love that
at 24 Cole is already dedicating himself
to helping others that's why Cole is on
the healer tribe if Cole is smart he'll
play the role of the 24 year old kid I'm
a wilderness guy but he's no dummy he
knows this game and he knows people desi
is smart accomplished she's a healer
she's been in the pageant world she
knows that she's attractive that is
something you can use out here to lure
people in and she's really charming if
the elements don't get to desi I think
desi goes a long way Joe was another one
of those guys he has such an engaging
personality and it's such a contrast to
his job he's a probation officer and
when you talked to him he says you know
I root for these people they made a
mistake they want to get back on the
right path and my job is to help them so
Joe's on the healer tribe but there's a
little bit of Tony and Joe that sort of
hunched over let me make some moves Joe
has to get into a strong alliance
initially and if he does and he can get
some momentum I think it's survivor
instincts will kick in and he'll do
really well Jessica loved Jessica she's
very principled and she's on the healer
tribe she really does put other people
first she wants to help you emotionally
physically in all ways she's there for
you but jessica is capable of coming in
and saying in my real life this is what
I do on Survivor
watch out because this is what I'm
capable of doing what we liked about dr.
Mike who is on the healer tribe he's a
urologist he has a great sense of humor
about helping them with their sex
problems and he's got a great confidence
about himself I think the biggest thing
going against my
like we'll be that he's a little bit
older and that if you judge him on a
first impression you might say is he
capable I would align with mine not
because I think I could beat him but
because I think we'd probably be better
with you on our group Roarke is
fascinating work is on the healer tribe
because that's what she does she helps
people with their emotional problems but
Roarke the survivor and she gets the
game she's one of those players that I
am imagining is always thinking but if
this then that could be this that means
that and this I see Roark lasting a long
time the only thing that would work
against Roark would be if her
personality didn't mesh or if she tried
to front that she was smarter than
people that wouldn't go well Ryan
loved Ryan the minute he walked in Ryan
is on the hustler tribe he's a bellhop
you don't make money if you don't
anticipate needs
he's very quick-witted he knows it and
he loves the game he's the first person
in 35 seasons to choose to wear a
turtleneck on Survivor a show that takes
place in a hundred degrees in Fiji he's
awesome Simone is on the hustle tribe
because if you look at her life story
she's been hustling since she came out
of the womb
she's a story of immigrants she's
overcome so much then she dedicated her
life giving back to people
everything about Simone says I will
never quit until I accomplish my goal
what Simone has going for her is she's
very bright she's a student of the game
what works against her is she's
analytical and she has to contemplate
things you have to be alive at all times
you cannot go inside and say let me
think Devon is on The Hustler tribe and
he represents a different kind of hustle
she's been given opportunities in life
and his attitude is not everybody gets
these so I'm not gonna squander it
he has such a goofy way about him and
he's giant guy physically fit but he's
wicked smart if people figure that out
sooner or later they have to get rid of
you so devon has to play up here right
away he's got to figure out how to find
people that'll keep him in the game
Lauryn is a third generation Fisher
woman I am a single mother in a
commercial fishing industry there's very
few of us and I think I'm a very small
breed she knows her way around a boat
hook net cage
but she's on The Hustler tribe because
she literally does not get paid if she
doesn't bring it back Lauren will be a
little bit of a fish out of water in
that she doesn't travel a lot she
doesn't leave her hometown very often
and here she is in the middle of Fiji
with a bunch of strangers from all over
the country so I think her opening
moment she's gonna have to break out of
any box that she has and just say hey my
name is Lauren what's up Patrick is a
wild card and at this point a question
mark for me he really is perfect for The
Hustler tribe he started his own
business he had to go basically
door-to-door to get it going but that
kind of a personality a big personality
with a big smile some people might look
at that and say I don't trust you
nobody's that happy Ali is on the
hustler tribe and even if you don't live
in Los Angeles you know that anybody
whose job title is personal assistant
they are hustling every day for somebody
to make sure all of their needs are met
you know every day is different and
every day I find out that I have a new
job she was a really amazing energy I
think Ali is gonna be one that's in it
for a long time I would be surprised if
she was out early I think she's way too
bright for that and it wouldn't surprise
me to see her at the end we have a lot
of superfans they know this game inside
out it is no longer a question of should
I make big moves the question now is
when do I make my big moves
[Music]
you